We are going live.
Yes.
If you guys can see us... we cannot see that
we are live yet... but we think we're live.
We're just in South Africa and everything is
a bit slow here with the wi-fi and everything.
But welcome to DLM Men's
Lifestyle's first live video and
we've got a big announcement to make
but before we do that let's wait a few
seconds for some more people to join.
Let's see who's here
Yeah me too.
Dave, Knoxville,
Tennessee, that's a place I want to visit
Son of David, oh you were here on DLM
Christian Lifestyle as well.
Yes that's awesome.
Thanks for joining us.
Ajara, Hey Samuel, good morning.
Oh it's evening here at 7
p.m here in South Africa.
We had a long day and now
we're here talking to you guys.
Hi Janine.
Hello another Samuel.
Nina Kruger. For those of you who
do not know that is Nikita' s mom.
Thank you for joining.
Look I'm on TV or video.
Yeah, if you guys don't know who's this
crazy lady next to me this is my wife Nikita.
For those of you who joined DLM Men's Lifestyle.
Yeah because people are probably wondering
what's the woman doing here.
I'm here because I'm celebrating
this amazing moment with my husband.
The publishing of his new book Bold Pursuit.
Show it show it show it.
Man, alright alright.
Alright right right Nikita helped me
and worked so hard, the team as well.
Here we go.
Bold Pursuit.
It is a big day today.
It is live everyone.
Thank you Lord Jesus.
We worked really hard
in this one and we need to pray that God
will change many lives through this book.
Yeah, speaking about the book, for
those of you that haven't purchased
it yet maybe you can go and have a look.
All the information on the book is in the video
description below and you can find it on either
our dlmchristianlifestyle.com website - just go
to the shop link - and then you'll see it there.
Or you can go to the book website directly
which is boldpursuitbook.com and you
can buy it at different retailers.
You buy it online and they ship
it to you all over the world.
I know it's not yet available in every
country but definitely in the United States.
It's there and Canada.
Yeah.
But you can get the eBook and audio book.
I've done the voice over myself.
We just did the video on Christian
Lifestyle and we shared a little bit
so some of you know this but some of the new
members here who are live they don't know
this but if you like jogging - if you like
driving - then you can get the audio book.
Man, this is special.
This is really special.
This is the second ... yeah, the second live ever.
That's so exciting.
I'm not that nervous anymore because we
did the first one just a few minutes ago.
But yeah - listen - before we
continue also some exciting news.
We are having a competition
at the end of this video.
We are giving away 10 free
copies of Bold Pursuit book.
So watch til the end of this video and
then we'll give you some more details.
Yeah.
But yeah Daniel
tell us a bit more about the book.
Give the viewers something exciting.
What was the inspiration behind it?
I just love it with Nikita on the channel.
The inspiration for the book
is first of all God, right?
He is the reason why I do the book
The reason I do the videos.
The reason I do everything is for God, right?
My love for Him and my love for
other people because of God.
I don't want people to one day stand
in front of God and He looks at them and says,
"Go away from me because I never knew you."
The day and age we live in today -
there are a lot of lukewarm Christians.
Yep.
And you know
we're so busy with this world - this rat race -
that people do not take their faith seriously.
They don't have a real relationship with
God and so this book is first of all to
bring them to the cross so that they can
understand what a true reborn Christian is.
Second, how to really grow spiritually
to understand that there's a lot more
than just getting your ticket to heaven.
There's a whole road of sanctification where you
learn certain things - how to fight through the
spirit, not through the flesh, you know, how to
come to the point of complete surrender where God
shows you who you are - your identity in Christ -
and you start to follow Him in everything you do.
And you understand - man - there's so
much that you still do not know.
There are a lot of people out there
who are Christians but they're still infants
in Christ. They're not mature Christians yet.
And you want to say something.
Alright.
No, I think it's it's also the the importance
of this book is just because we live in a day
and age where men - the essence of being
a man - is being brought down so much
and the identity of what a man is or supposed to
be - especially a Godly man is - is being taken
away - out of the equation - almost yeah... it's
been attacked on all fronts, and that is why it's
so important to ask a man to boldly pursue God
without any fear, without any worrying about what
people around you would say, right Daniel?
Yes, because that was actually a question.
Why the name Bold Pursuit?
That was a question on
the Christian Lifestyle comments.
You can pursue all the wrong things to try
and get peace and fulfillment in this life, you
know, but nothing can give you that except God.
There's nothing out there that
is more important than this.
This world is so short.
I learned that from the
death of my two brothers and I know I talk
about it a lot but that is the reality.
We have a date where we will be
born and a date where we will die.
You cannot run away from death and so
you want to be sure that you are saved.
Yeah, there's nothing more
important than pursuing God.
But after you find him there's
a whole new world that opens up.
A new spiritual world where you
start to see the world differently.
I can talk about this the whole
day but I think we should start.
Let's give them an overview of this video today.
Yes.
So the overview of the video is just going to be
well we've already kind of discussed the book oh
and yes, just one more thing about the book, in
the coming few weeks we are going to be posting
quotes - special quotes - from Daniel's book.
So keep a look out for that on our social media
and we are also going to share a discussion
guide that you can use with your Bible study
group or even with your home study when you are
with family or friends that is going to be really
really really helpful. Yeah, keep your eyes out.
Because for ministries - for churches - this is
very important.
And pastors.
And everybody can use it so we will post
that and you can also - I forgot about
it - you can also download the free chapter
on the official boldpursuitbook.com website
and then in the rest of the video we
are going to share you with you guys
"Day 52...What is a Man's Role in the Marriage".
We're going to answer a few questions and then
we're going to end it off by giving you
the details of the competition right?
Right ... the end of this video.
So we'll probably be
yeah around 20 more minutes but but guys this is
an informal video - this is just us wanting to
spend time with you and I want you to understand
that I'm just a normal human being - Nikita as
well - and we just want to spend time with our
DLM family and we're going to look at the comments
every now and then here to see what you guys are
saying and especially after we go through Day 52,
a man's role in marriage.
Then we're gonna look at a few
questions but I think we should start.
Yeah, let's pray.
I'll pray.
I'll do a quick prayer.
Father, just thank you so much for helping me to
write this book and I pray Father that you would
bless it so that people will be saved and that
they will really pursue you no matter the cost.
And I want to ask Father that you will
be with us here in this Bible study.
Help us to clear out all distractions
of this world and talk to us today.
Amen.
Thank you Daniel.
Alright, Day 52, a man's role in marriage.
Yeah, so I'm not gonna share the book here with
you because some of you are going to go ahead and
read it while we're gonna have a discussion
over it so we're gonna read it on this side
and I'm gonna ask Nikita to read a little bit
here and there as well but let's get to it.
Day 52, a husband's role in marriage.
I always start with a Bible verse.
So important in the day and age we live in today.
Because people don't follow sound doctrine.
They don't follow the Bible.
They follow what they feel
like and you can't do that.
You can't live that way.
So first of all, Ephesians 5:25.
husbands - oh for those of you who
are not husbands yet - you also need to listen
so that when you are married, you don't think,
oh man, what should I do.
How should I be a good husband?
You should learn how to be
a good husband, right now.
Husbands, love your wives just
as Christ also loved the church.
That means the way that God loves you,
brothers and sisters in Christ.
We are the church, right?
So I'll say it - I'll read it again.
Husbands, love your wives, just as Christ
also loved the church and gave Himself up for her.
Are you ready to give yourself up for your wife?
My dad said this to me once.
You know, when I talked about Nikita and I'm
praying for a wife and he said don't marry her if
you're not willing to give up your life for her.
That was ... that was what he asked me and so
you need to ask yourself that question as well.
And apologies if we're gonna cough now and then..
I just got through a flu .... Nikita as well.
It is what it is.
But thank you guys for praying.
We asked you guys on the Telegram to pray
for me so thank you, I'm a lot better.
And Nikita, sorry about that.
Halfway there.
Alright, so let's continue.
God created marriage.
Full stop.
God created marriage?
We forget, right, sometimes we think,
oh it's my marriage. We're married.
God created marriage.
He understands the relational math that allows
two to become one without subtracting anything.
That's important to understand.
He designed us so that we can connect
in an extraordinary way with someone
else and experience amazing love, joy,
and fulfillment from that connection.
I've said in the other video but I want
to say it here for some of you who might
not have seen it - you know, marriage
can be one of the most amazing things.
Nikita and I - we've been married for
13 years and Nikita is a blessing let
me tell you that I could not have asked
for a better wife, that supports me.
Man, I'm not going to go into this - we're going
to get emotional here - but if God
is in the marriage, it is a blessing.
But if he's not, it can be one of the worst
things that you will ever experience in this life.
Let's continue.
Maybe you want to read a little bit.
Yeah, sure.
Let me just read that last part again.
And experience amazing love, joy,
and fulfillment from that connection.
So, when God talks about marriage
in his Word we should pay attention.
Unfortunately there are a lot of
people who aren't paying attention.
Studies show that over the past
40 years, the divorce rate has
more than doubled globally.
Oh my word, that's insane.
Yeah, when you have broken
families you have broken societies.
And so marriage is extremely important.
We forget how important it is.
So it has doubled globally.
Combating this trend begins with
understanding the unique roles God created
for husbands and wives within a marriage.
Husbands and wives.
Let's look at what God's
Word says about the role of a husband.
Ephesians 5:25 and then 28 to 30 - says
husbands love your wives just as Christ also
loved the church and gave Himself up for her.
So husbands also ought to love
their own wives as their own bodies.
Their own wives.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's... that's so strong.
He who loves his own wife loves himself.
For no one ever hated his own flesh but
nourishes and cherishes it just
as Christ also does the church.
Because we are part of His body.
As you love your body and yourself you
should also love your wife.
You nourish it,
which you cherish your wife, right?
That's how you should look at your wife.
I think a lot of husbands today are too selfish
because that's the world we live in today, right?
You scroll on social media and its
just self this and self that, right?
Self-love, self-importance, self-respect.
But what has God say that we have to do?
Deny yourself pick up your cross and follow Me.
There is no place for... I've said
it before and in this video as well....
But I'll say it here for people who are selfish
in marriage .. that marriage won't work.
Sorry Nikita. You can continue.
OK. I'll read the section then
you... then you read the next.
Alright.
The love Paul is talking
about is a commitment to actively love your
spouse even when you're not feeling the romance.
The Eros of love .. so I'm just gonna
read this section again ... because this
is the most important almost of this whole
piece... the love Paul is talking about is
a commitment to actively love your spouse
even when you're not feeling that romance.
Paul is talking about agape.
Agape?
Agape.
Agape, that's right.
Paul is talking about agape love, the
sacrificial love that Christ has for the church.
This love is forgiving.
It compels us to work to restore
our relationship after we've been wronged.
This section is also very important.
This makes .. and I just want to share something
here... because a lot of people just focus on the
Eros love, right?
The attraction.
But that's not going to carry you through.
Marriage is hard work and so you need to
love the other person the way God loves
them with unconditional agape love.
No matter what they do.
You look at your wife.
You know when she is angry but you don't... you
know... you don't react to that through the flesh.
You put on that switch - you act
through the spirit - you love her
and you understand that she's also just a human.
She make mistakes here and there, just like you.
Yeah, sometimes we might not
like each other that much.
but you ... I'm just kidding ...
but you have to love your husband
or your wife because God loves them.
That is what agape love means, right?
Unconditional.
Yeah.
So it's not a feeling.
It's an act of your will.
Yes.
Sacrificial love is encouraging.
It's quick to overlook mistakes and annoyances.
It's
humbling.
It inspires us to make our
own needs and wants secondary.
Exactly what you said.
A lot of people think, man, my wife doesn't
do this enough - she doesn't - she should do
this more - I need this ...I - I - I - I ...
and you don't really realize it and you throw
a pity party for yourself.
Oh, she doesn't love you.
So she doesn't.
Oh look at that wife.
Look what she is doing for her husband.
Yeah, you shouldn't do that.
You should think, alright,
what does my wife need from me?
You are the action - and then
she will react to your action.
Don't want to have - you shouldn't
want to have the perfect wife.
You should need to want to be the
perfect husband and vice versa.
Don't want the perfect husband.
Try and be the perfect wife.
Well said.
Next.
Do you want to continue?
No, you can go to the next section.
Alright, so God demands (there's a cough
coming) God demands that we as men treat
our wives in an understanding way.
Sometimes that can be difficult.
But you need to realize that
they are unique and different.
They don't think like you.
They are different.
You need to just come to the
place where you accept it
at the beginning of my marriage.
You know, I thought, man, why is Nikita so
different in this and this and this?
Well, God made us different.
It would be so boring if we
were all the same, right?
We need to treat them gently,
with love and patience.
And I just want to say here you know my mom -
growing up - my mom - Ma Trudie - she always said
and I'll say this in Afrikaans because you guys
know we speak Afrikaans as our first language.
Danie, behandel jou vrou sagkens. She would always
say you have to treat your wife in a gentle way.
And I will never forget that.
Thank you, mom.
You're probably listening.
But it is so true.
We need to treat them gently, with love and
patience, in the same way God takes care of us.
Wow, did you hear that?
That's how you should treat
your wife, the same way God takes care of us.
It's not a bossy way - it's a loving way.
Hmm ...that's so powerful.
It is so important to Him that if we do not
obey Him in this, our prayers will be hindered.
One Peter 3 verse 7 - so if you ... even for you
who think that you're very religious
... you go and you're praying.
You do a lot of things for God but at
home your relationship with your wife
is not right. You can leave what you're
doing, you go back and you make it right.
Do not go and sleep when you're still angry.
Where there's something that's ... that's
you feel it.. there's still
something between me and my wife.
It's your responsibility to go and make it
right, if you want God to listen to your prayers.
Such an important verse.
In Matthew 19 verse 46, Jesus emphasized
the sacred nature of the marriage....
That's alright.
...the marriage relationship responding
to a question about divorce he said this:
Have you not read that He who created them
from the beginning made them male and female.
I just want to pause here.
Did you hear that? Male and female.
Not a donkey, a unicorn or some
other thing you want to identify as.
Male and female.
That's the truth.
You know people say that I have
my truth or if you - your truth.
No.
We have different perspectives of the truth.
There's only one truth - that's God's truth.
Yep.
Oh lost my place here...
Here we go.
Male and female and said for
this reason a man shall leave
his father and mother and be joined to his wife.
And the two shall become one flesh so they are no
longer two but one flesh.
This is so important.
There are husbands out there who are
allowing his parents to interfere with
marriage. That shouldn't happen.
You walked away from them.
You have a marriage now with your wife.
And with God they are first.
So don't allow other people to interfere.
Yeah, and what I want to add
something also to this.
Because it's not necessarily
always people that from their own active world
that want to interfere into your relationship.
It is sometimes you - yourself - that cause -
that drags people into your relationship and
your problems.
Right.
And then that makes them become, you know, part of
it, and ... and what I'm actually referring to is,
for example, as women I know that we are emotional
and when you had a little argument or a little
spat with your husband you just want to vent about
it and you want to get it off your chest and you
want to cry about it and then what we usually
do - the first thing is - if you've got a good
relationship with your mom you'll get on the phone
- you'll call your mom or you call ... you will
call your friends and just you know, vent, and
get it out and ramble on about what just happened.
And that is the worst thing
that you can actually do.
I know that we need to get things off our
chest but ladies the best thing that you
could ever do is to go to the Bible
and work with the Lord through the
problem and the thing and go to your husband.
I mean you're in a relationship - you're in
a marriage for a reason - to share these
things to support and uplift each other.
And help each other and you need to let your
husband know what is going on in your mind.
If you aren't happy with things and also
the husband with the wife because if you
go to that other person to vent,
it just turns into gossip later.
And it creates a really bad and sour
relationship between your husband then
and that other person that you've vented
with, you know, so it's really important.
Don't share your personal stuff with other
people and make them part of the issue.
There are things that should stay in marriage.
Nikita and I - we have a rule. You know
sometimes when we have a disagreement
we never act in the flesh, right?
We tell ourselves don't act in a
flesh and when you're a little bit filled
that you're a bit heated, go to scripture,
find out what the Bible says, come back.
Amen, solve the problem.
Nikita thinks this... I think this...
OK, but what does the Bible say?
What is the truth?
So let's continue here.
Therefore what God has joined
together no person is to separate.
Marriage isn't just a promise between a
husband and a wife, it's a promise to God.
Too many people divorce too easily today because
they are not willing to sacrifice the self-life
and work hard at marriage, a promise to remain
with your spouse for the rest of your life.
It's a promise that takes
quite a bit of work to fulfill.
It's not easy.
Falling in love is easy.
It's very easy.
Staying in love is a challenge for most people.
The key ... listen closely... because this
is the key that unlocks a good marriage.
The key to a successful marriage lies in having
agape love at all times through the Spirit.
I cannot stress this enough.
Say it again.
Alright, the key to a successful marriage
lies in having agape love at all times.
Through the Spirit.
Yes, if you... if you always put God first,
you will have an amazing marriage.
Amen.
And I'm gonna ask you to dig deep
at the end of every daily devotion.
I'll ask you to do some self-reflection.
In Ephesians 5:23, Paul said:
For the husband is the head of the wife
as Christ also is the head of the church.
If a husband takes this responsibility
seriously and leads in a Christ-like way,
his wife and children will gladly follow him.
If you treat your wife like a queen,
she will treat you like a king.
If you walk like Jesus, because
that's our aim, right, as reborn Christians to
follow in the footsteps of Jesus, to be like Him,
then it will be easy for your wife to follow you.
Because all you're doing is just following what
God's Word says and then she needs to listen to
you but if you say certain things that are outside
of God's word she doesn't need to listen to you.
So you're not the boss - you're the leader - that
leads gently the way that Christ leads the church.
Amen.
Ask yourself the following questions
and answer them truthfully.
Are you ready for this?
If you want to, you guys can answer
there in the live chat or in the comment section.
First question.... Nikita, maybe you wanna?
Yeah sure.
Read (the question)... Question:
Do you lead your wife in a loving and
gentle manner like Christ leads the church?
We can't answer this for you... you
need to answer this and question two...
what does a husband's sacrificial
love look like in a healthy marriage?
I wonder... these questions are very
deep and so you shouldn't just brush
it off and quickly answer it.
You need to think about it and
be truthful with yourself.
It doesn't if... if you are
truthful and if you deny some of the truth that
you know is fact of how you treat your wife
or how you are in your marriage, then you are
going to be worse off if you lie to yourself.
If you're not honest.
Because you need to truthfully be honest yourself
to know where the places in your personality are
or in in the issues that you need to work on,
right?
Right.
And I just want to say that this is very
important for a lot of men to understand.
You know the role of a husband.
We talked about the role of a wife
as well on the DLM Christian Lifestyle and you
know when I talk about these things I see children
and I feel my heart goes out to a lot of kids,
you know, who are being abandoned by a father.
In South Africa, we have
a lot of fatherless homes.
Be a man.
Man up.
I have the merch on today - man up.
You can get this merch in the video
description if you like it.
But you need to man up.
Yep, you need to act in the spirit.
Be like Christ.
Take your responsibility as a
husband - as a father - seriously.
Yeah.
And for... I know that there's
a certain amount of .... a certain percentage of
women that also follow DLM Men's Lifestyle that
we've seen on the demographics so... around 10
to15 percent... thank you, by the way, thank you.
And for those women that are specifically watching
- or even husbands if you are watching now - and
you want to maybe call your wife and tell them to
listen to the section whilst it is very important
like Daniel said we also discussed the role
of the wife in the Christian Lifestyle video,
if you want to go over and have a look at that.
But it is important that the wife also knows these
things and as the husband loves the wife the wife
needs to be respectful and kind and gentle and
caring also to her husband back because it's easy
to say yes, the husband needs to be the action to
get the proper and correct reaction from his wife,
and he needs to be the leader but then again if
you aren't the correct support system and you
know like a proper Christian support system for
your husband it's also not going to work.
So it's not... I've heard people say
a relationship or marriage is 50-50.
No that's not it. It's actually 100-100.
You need to put in all your effort and all your
strength that you can into your marriage. And
the day that you feel like you can only
give 80 percent - that's when the other
person compromises and does 120 percent.
Man, I've got an amazing wife right?
I make a lot of mistakes too but that's
why I can share my experience and my advice
so I think we should move over.
Before we tell you guys about the competition
let's take a look at a few questions here.
Do you guys have any questions about the book
and I just want to share this a little bit right?
You can buy different books on different topics
but this book deals with those different topics.
90 days ...90 daily devotionals that
you can do and it doesn't take long.
You see how we work through this very quick
and yeah I would love your support on this
book and I just want to thank you guys - thank
you for the support on my channel for the...
I mean we're almost 1 million... that's
that's amazing what God has been doing.
I've seen Nikita already looking at... sorry I'm
looking at the comments... top chat here... OK,
yeah on that note... thank you so
much for the support everybody.
Just a quick side note on that.
We really appreciate it.
Alright so we do have a little bit of a delay here
with the Wi-Fi but let's see uh Dylan says can't
wait to get the book it should be coming today.
God bless.
Yeah it is coming today.
It is out.
You can get it right now in America and Canada.
Get in the stores ... you can also.... Nikita
shared at the beginning of this video
you can go to boldpursuitbook.com.
You'll see all the links there.
You can get it on Amazon.
There's a few places you can get it.
It's going to come out a little bit
later at different countries like South
Africa's will be a little bit later this
year... like places like CUM Books, Exclusive
Books ... but it doesn't matter where you live,
you can get the eBook and audio book that I've
done a voice over so that will definitely help
for those of you who like cycling
Yeah, jogging, driving far and
just listen to me reading the book.
Any more questions about the book guys?
We are going to give a few more seconds
for the questions to come through if you
have questions that you want to ask us...
specifically with regards to the book.
What are some of the other questions
on the Christian Lifestyle Channel that
we got? I just want to give a quick while
you think ... shout out to Kevin Hawthorne
from Florida .. man thank you so much. I see you
in the premieres ... in the live chat a lot and I
just want to thank you for your support.
God bless you and your family.
Yes, thank you so much.
Alright, so one of the
other questions that is asked is - what
is the reason for the name Bold Pursuit?
Well, yeah, we talked about that a little bit at
the beginning of the video but if you just joined,
Bold Pursuit is about truly pursuing
Jesus Christ no matter the cost.
You know, the disciples followed
Jesus and what they had .. what a
lot of people don't have today... is they
came to the point of complete surrender
where God is first above
everything else in our lives.
So Bold Pursuit is really
about pursuing Jesus Christ.
There's nothing more important than that.
A lot of people pursue alcohol, gambling,
you know... playing games... there
are different things that people try
to find that peace you know, unconditional
peace, that surpasses all understanding.
But you can only find that in Jesus.
Yeah.
So, um, let's look at some of the questions here.
Someone else asked what is agape?
Agape I struggle with that one... agape love ...is
the love that God has for you. Unconditional.
He loved you while you were still a
sinner... He doesn't love your sin
but He loves you unconditionally and that's
the same kind of love that we have received
from God when we became reborn Christians.
We received His spirit in us and that also
gives us the ability to love
other people through His love.
Unconditional love... it means that it
doesn't matter what Nikita does if she
screams at me I'm not gonna not love her anymore
I'm gonna love her so that's unconditional love.
Eros love .. is that kind of
love that's more romantic, right?
But between a husband and a wife.
Eros love sometimes will come and go
because you will have disagreements. Marriage
is hard work but it is the agape love that
will carry you through until the end. Yeah.
And there's another good question from Janine.
What other topics are you going to
be covering in your book Daniel?
There's a few topics like how ... yeah.... how
to fight through the Spirit and not the flesh.
How to come to the point of complete surrender.
There's a few things like the gifts of the Spirit.
There's a few things it will really help you
to to boost your spiritual growth in Christ.
Yes.
And I just want to mention for the ladies
on the channel and husbands even you guys
can buy it for your wives.
This is... I know the book
is specifically targeted at men but
it's a really really really good book.
I read it and I can honestly say that it
is very insightful for women too because
obviously like this section it will help
you to understand for example the role of
the husband also and it is just something
that you can honestly use in your own life.
You know, advice and knowledge and how to navigate
your relationship and grow in your relationship
with God .
Yeah.
So it's good for women too.
I just want to say to Janine as well
when you look at the the back of the the book,
there are a few things here as well that you can
experience while you explore the book.
How to worship God in Spirit and in truth.
What it means to engage in spiritual battle...
what sin is and isn't... and why it matters.
Where to find hope when you're feeling hopeless.
Practical ways to overcome destructive
habits and addictions.
Oh this is so important.
A lot of men are struggling
with pornography today.
We get a lot of emails.
Yeah.
So this will help and how to make Bible study and
prayer an integrated part of your life but at the
end of it after reading this book my prayer is
that you would come to the point of complete
surrender because that changes everything.
Yeah.
If you don't know what that means you
can... you can have a look on the DLM
Christian Lifestyle channel where I
shared videos on complete surrender.
Yeah.
You want to share something?
Yeah, now I just want to say it
is the moment for the competition.
Exciting exciting times.
Like I said before, we are giving
away 10 free copies of the book Bold Pursuit.
Now, how can you enter this competition?
You need to listen carefully and
unfortunately this is only for USA
residents and Canadian residents.
Only USA and Canada.
Because that's where the book is
available in hard copy right now.
The question that we want the answer to is...
oh just so you know you need to be fast right?
Because there's a lot of people.
Send it to me on Twitter, DM me at
DanielLMaritz, my new Twitter page.
Or they call it X today don't they.
I've got no idea.
So send it to me when you know the answer.
OK, are you ready?
Yes and the question is:
What is the last Bible verse that Daniel quoted
on last week's DLM Christian Lifestyle video?
So you need to go to his other channel,
DLM Christian Lifestyle, and watch the
last video which is called Follow Jesus No
Matter the Cost - Bold Pursuit Bible study.
We'll put the link in the
video description for you guys.
So the question is again... I'm going to
repeat ....what is the last Bible verse
that Daniel quoted on last week's
DLM Christian Lifestyle video?
Remember the first 10
correct answers get the book.
Yes, that DMs Daniel on his
Twitter account, DanielLMaritz,
but we'll also put that in the video description.
I'll send it to you and that video is called
Follow Jesus No Matter the Cost.
Yeah, so important.
Bold Pursuit Bible study.
Yes.
Alright, let's just have a look here... is
there any last questions about the book?
Let's see here.... I see Matthew question
mark Janine... Marcus ...thanks for the
ESV recommendations you carry and I got a copy.
Nice.
Thank you Sandra.
Yes, I agree with what you said
about book is good for women too.
Great.
Crystal Nakuru.
OK, that's about someone else.
Janine fast fingers up good luck US and Canadians.
Alright, OK, it looks like there's
not a lot of questions anymore.
I just want to thank you guys for all the support.
Please share the video to your husband - your
father - your uncles - your
grandfathers - your sons - we
need more spiritual men who are not afraid.
Who are bold, who want to follow Jesus Christ
no matter the cost like David.
You can come to that
point and say, Father, here I am.
Take out everything that is not right and they
need to pursue Jesus Christ no matter the cost.
There's nothing more important than that in this
short temporary world.
Amen.
So guys, thank you for joining and
remember God loves you and we love you too.
We love you too.
Bye guys.
Now I just need to get to the exit button...
see we're not used to... where is it...bye.